[Music]
the Black Panther has protected more
outdoor generation this is your time
[Music]
the world's gonna start over
mr. king this ends today
sweet Christmas everyone we got some new
Black Panther footage to break down and
it looks so much better than the
previous trailer so you can tell that
they're still finishing some of the CG
if you're finding me for the first time
I'm doing videos all throughout the
holiday so be sure to subscribe to get
everything and I'm doing that Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway so I'll explain that
at the end of the video
like you watch Sheree showing him his
new black panther costume it looks like
her lab is actually in the same facility
is the great mount where they mine all
their vibranium from but then you turn
around and you see all this graffiti art
on the staircase that winds up so I
don't know if they did that with CG and
they added it later or if that's just a
shot that we haven't seen before and
they painted that on practically but the
interesting thing here is that it's
missing the third Black Panther costume
that's just the necklace on the white
dummy it might just be obscured by them
but it looks like they digitally deleted
it or it's from a different take from a
different part of the movie it's gold
like the golden Jaguar costume the kill
monger is wearing that actually might be
where he gets his costume from but you
have to remember that there's a bunch of
different tribes in Wakanda some of them
are incredibly powerful so they would
have some of this technology too but the
whole idea is is that Black Panthers
family is the most badass family so
whatever technology the rival tribes
like moon Baku man Apes tribe is one of
the rival tribes anything that they can
rustle up Sheree could actually top
because she's supposed to be so much
smarter but the funny thing about this
aside from the new footage when you
think about it they dropped this on
Christmas
Black Panther himself does not celebrate
Christmas because he worships the
Panther God so we haven't really talked
about that aspect of the Marvel Universe
the way that religion at least on planet
Earth influences their culture it have
all their costumes their art their
superpowers derived from that so the
really cool thing is that it actually
has a lot in common with the Thor
character from the comics and that it's
a combination of mysticism in science
like really high level science that
seems like magic at times even if you're
not a big comic book reader they've
actually explained it through the Doctor
Strange comics that is basically drawing
energy from other dimensions we harness
and
drawn from other dimensions of the
multiverse to cast spells to conjure
shields and weapons to make
so even thor ragnarok introduces the
concept of actual gods in the Marvel
Universe that's really just one
interpretation the way that Thor gets
his power from Asgard but Asgard isn't a
place it's a people so he literally gets
his power from his people so it's a very
mystical idea that they didn't fully
explain during Thor Ragnarok but it's
just another spin on the high-level
science that you get into with guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 in the concept of
marbles Celestials ego the Living Planet
literally a brain bloating in space for
eons that slowly learns to manipulate
matter around himself so that he forms
himself a body so if you're wondering
how it is that Thor can be a God in the
Marvel Universe if technically we
haven't got to the idea of real gods
like God in the way that you would talk
about a Christian God or the God of
another faith something that exists on a
higher plane of reality versus something
like Dormammu who is all-powerful but
it's really just a being from a
different dimension that has slowly
gained power and control of an entire
dimension so as far as they've explained
you just have all these people on the
same level of existence that just have
varying levels of power based on their
biology so the Celestials are supposed
to be the most powerful people that we
met so far not including Thanos wildung
the Infinity Gauntlet so it'll be
interesting to see how they incorporate
the idea of the Panther God into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe because you
see him walking around here on what
looks like a different plane of
existence which is sort of the realm
that the souls go to when their citizens
die so like he might be talking to the
Panther God because you see all of them
sitting in this tree here we made all
kinds of theories about how this might
be the soul world of the soul gem now
that hasn't been confirmed nothing that
they've had in any of the trailers gives
that away but that's mostly just because
they've gotten really good at omitting
things with CG like Thor's eye from Thor
Ragnarok
I actually just posted that Thor
Ragnarok video which has a bunch of the
VFX in it but right now in the comics
the last 10 15 years or so the Black
Panther character gets some of his more
mystical abilities
from his connection to the Panther God
his physical abilities obviously come
from the heart-shaped herb that he gets
from the vibranium tainted soil so we
have that Captain America team up for
the outriders invasion in the infinity
war trailer it'll be interesting to see
how their fighting styles differ because
they didn't do too much fighting during
Captain America Civil War cap is a total
badass but he's like that Superman type
character someone who pulls his punches
because he doesn't want to hurt people
more than he has to Black Panther
doesn't give a crap about any of that
but even if they were the same strength
level I would say that this MCU version
of Black Panther could probably still
beat Captain America but one of the best
examples for how strong his suit makes
him in addition to the heart-shaped herb
is when he's clawing out the tire in the
axle on this car here so they're going
super fast so you're already generating
all this force even if you had special
gloves on and you stuck your fingers
into the axle of a car your fingers
would fly off that's how much force is
being generated by that spinning wheel
the reason why Black Panther is able to
do that is one because vibranium cuts
through other metal like butter but also
because the energy suit helps diffuse
energy sure he gives him that big speech
about all the things that it does I'll
link that trailer at the end of this
look she goes through all the abilities
that the suit gives him on top of his
normal abilities the difference in this
suit is the Iron Man level abilities
where it just forms around to him like
Iron Man armor but it also absorbs
energy and stores it for later use so he
can give that off as pulses later but it
also aids him when he's trying to claw
this wheel out but hopefully you're all
having a great holiday there's a Doctor
Who Christmas special that I'll do a
video for but there's gonna be a bunch
of other comic book stuff dropping in
the next couple of weeks
especially because Black Panther is
happening right after the Superbowl
early in February so you have any comic
book video requests for a Marvel or DC
stuff just leave them in the comments
below I'll be doing regular videos all
throughout the holiday through the new
year so no worries
congratulations to the new Infinity
Gauntlet winner mr. crunch please
private message me so I can get your
contact details I'll name a new winner
when I post new Marvel that should be in
the next day or two click here for all
that badass Thor footage and click here
for a brand new dead
- thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome happy holidays
[Music]